I'd like to say something about
ethno-nationalism because it's one of
the characteristics of this dark time
we're living and maybe as a result of
the fact that we're living in an age of
unprecedented global migration with 65
million people on the move there is now
a renaissance of fantasies of
homogeneity more and more nations are
coming to believe that they should live
only with and among people like
themselves wait man this is Jerry I'll
tell you why it's a fantasy because
there never is a community homogeneous
enough to constitute what we mean by a
nation when European nationalism was
first started in the late 18th and early
19th century it began with an idea of a
perfect fit that there is a state and
there is a nation and the borders of the
state should in Carton should be the
borders of the nation and every nation
would be incarnated by a state and it
would all be very neat the problem was
it that it was never neat and there
developed this thing that became known
in the early 20th century as the problem
of minorities because there were always
people within the homogeneous community
who were heterogeneous yeah until
finance well until finally there are
people who came to two conclusions one
they don't need to live among people
like themselves to be themselves they
just need to be free and two there is no
greater source of social conflict and
state conflict than the fantasy of
perfect homogeneity and what I fail to
understand is you never come on oh you
do I have I have a concept I do
I have a concept of people in German
folk living in a country in a
nation-state in a territory but I know
it is never and it has never been
totally homogeneous like say kind of
whatever marbles in the little pack that
are totally all a green are all a blue
is not a technical then why are you
worried about them why are you worried
about the immigrants because what are
they stealing from you know I'm a no
stealing anything from me but I strongly
believe that it is a people that has to
be almost and are mostly homogeneous
being totally homogeneous as a fantasy
this is stupid
it's kind of a technical concept like
but if they but excuse me if you look we
have historical experience here if you
look at the history of the treatment of
minorities by nation states it is true
in theory that you can have a state in
which you have a large homogeneous
population and then a small minority or
minorities but if you look at the wait
wait experience has shown us that people
who are who are excited by the fold and
who are excited by people like
themselves generally wind up losing
tolerance or worse with the minorities
with whom they live so why wouldn't it
be easier and more just and more moral
to simply rely upon a pluralist
democracy in which everyone who lives in
the country has the same rights and each
community can flourish according to its
power ok so I have one last question to
you mr. visiter this is why is this why
is Israel and exception for you so you
first you bring up the Mossad now you
bring up Israel yeah because I'm because
I'm interested in this in your eyes
Grill is a nation-state must this is a
great problem that faces Israel right
now oh I don't think you're not I think
Germany should disappear no no I'm all
for nation-states but I think that
the nation that would that lives within
the state should be conceived
heterogeneous Li not homogeneous Li I'm
not for the disavow I think the
nation-state is here to stay and it's
probably a good thing the problem that
Israel's facing is that Zionism in some
ways imported the European idea of
nationalism this theory of the perfect
fit and then the Israelis discovered the
Jews of Israel discovered not only that
there before 67 that there were Arabs
living in their midst and after 67 as a
result of a war of self-defense not of a
war of conquest that there were millions
of Palestinians living if not with some
than right alongside them and the
problem that you're facing is I tell my
Israeli friends that's the problem that
they're facing and at some point they
will have the same choice that European
countries will they will either become
multi-ethnic and pluralistic or they
will become fascist than homogeneous
those are the only two possible
[Applause]
you